hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
match between paul charles murphy and
daniel harvitz and this is game six
now i already made this video but this
morning
uh my windows got updated and it
switched uh
from the main microphone from my blue
yeti to the camera microphone and then
it just was
really terrible so now i have to record
it again but it's not a problem because
now i
uh you know know the game much better
and for those
who are just joining us uh this is game
six uh morphe started the match by
losing two games then
morphe retaliated in in great style he
won the next three games this is now
game four and after losing those two
games
uh morphy said that harvest will not win
a single game so we're still we're still
checking if this will be true
or not but uh well i'll best adjust if
we check out the game so morphe again
with the white pieces and again
morphe opens with e4 we have e5 by
harvest knight to f3
and the d6 again uh harvest goes for the
philadelphia defense and the morphe
sticks with the d4 if it works uh you
know
or what it's like if it's not broken
don't
fix it or something like that but yeah
he captures we have queen captures again
and
in game four if you remember we had
knight to c6 attacks the queen then
bishop pins the knight bishop here
characters captures the game continues
and morphe won a very nice game but here
harvest decided to mix it up a little
bit he played knight to f6
and uh morphy took this opportunity to
not continue development which is
strange as morphe is a big fan of
development
he immediately strikes in the center
with e5
and now okay you want to go after the
queen you want to get your knight to the
e5 put some pressure on f7
uh all makes sense and black accepts
this we have d
captures on e5 queen capture 78 with
check king captures and now knight
captures an e5
threatening to capture on f7 which would
win the rook so bishop to e6 defending
this
and now knight to c3 we have bishop to
d6
attacking the knight here and now knight
to c4
so the bishop on d6 is under attack and
this is a pretty open game so you should
kind of keep an eye on your bishop
pair and probably bishop to c5 or bishop
to b4 is
is the way to go here but harvest
decided that
he's just going to capture on c4 and uh
that's just it he's not interested in
keeping the bishop
pair and morphy says all right this only
helps me develop my light square bishop
i'm putting pressure on your f7 pawn
and now you don't want to play something
like kink to e7 to defend it then bishop
to g5 is coming queen side
uh the other rook is coming to e1 and
the black king could be a bit vulnerable
here so first
rook the e8 with check bishop to e3
and only now king to e7 so sort of uh
castling artificially
uh we have queen side castles by morphe
and now
a6 taking away the b5 square from
morphe's pieces with bishop to g5 now
pinning the knight
and knight to b7 here you should play
king to f8
and allow this doubling of the pawns
because knights to d7
is not much better you don't really gain
anything by this
uh morphe goes after the knight twice
knight to e4
again puts pressure on the bishop and
again maybe you could to shift the
bishop somewhere like b6
harvest even forces a trade we have h6
uh morphe captures a way to check knight
captures and now
knight captures on d6 we have c captures
on d6 and now just
rook to h1 check king to f8 and we have
rook captures on h8 and now you can't
bring a rook into the game because the
d6 pawn is hanging so the knight has to
capture
we have knight captures on e8 and now we
have bishop to d5
and now that all has been said and done
we have this
end game where the material is equal but
morphe has a bishop against tonight
which is a little bit better because the
play is on both sides of the board
meaning the pawns are on both sides of
the board uh and morphy has a
slightly better pawn structure as he has
two pawn islands uh
harvest has three pawn island so it
could be a bit trickier
defending uh but okay a rook to b8
getting the rook out of harm's way
now preparing to advance the pawn on the
queen side and now
bishop back to f3 so again you can't
move the knight the d6 pawn will fall
so g6 and now c3 both players prepare to
bring their king into the game
king to e7 and now rook to e1 with
check king to f8 here king to d7
is actually very very interesting but
harvest was afraid that after this move
attacking the pawn and f6 this bishop to
e6 check would be problematic but
the point is if you move the king
somewhere like this then bishop here is
it is a problematic move but if you go
king to e7 which looks very counter
intuitive the rook is here
there are no good discoveries for the
for the bishop so here you really don't
have anything bishop d5 you could just
continue with with a perpetual here so
not not much happening here
so after rook the e1 check we have king
back to f8 harvest decides to go about
it this way
and now king to c2 now morphy starts
bringing the king into the game now we
have knight to c7
uh and now king to b3 we have knight to
the e6
and now king the a4 and now if morphy
can get king a5
uh king a5 king b6 and king to a7 and
then it's game over
he kicks the rook away attacks the b7
pawn attacks the a6 pawn gobbles up
everything and that's game over so of
course the b6 has to be played
creating a wall here uh so morphe king
and morphy's king cannot approach
approach those pawns
we have b4 now morphy prepares king b3
and a4
now he wants to start expanding those
pawns on the queen side
and h5 morphe closes the position here
we have h4 and
king to e7 now uh we have rook to e3
helping out with the defense along the
third rank
uh and king to d7 now we have bishop to
d5
and now if the king of course moves then
you just pick up the
the knight and the pawn that's how it
works uh
so rook to e8 and not king back to b3
uh preparing a4 and further expansion on
the queen side
uh you do have three against two on the
queen side but
this isolated d-pawn still will make it
problematic for white to create any
uh any sort of uh pass pawns uh on the
queen side so here
rook the g8 preparing g5 to create a
semi-open g file
uh to be used for for the black rook and
now rook to f3 going after the f7 pawn
we have king to e7 and now a4 by morphe
with
a5 and now comes bishop captures on e6
and here
you have this position where uh one move
is a great one move is
not so great uh so here what would you
recapture with would you capture back
with the king or or with the f7 pawn
you don't have to pause the video just
you know what does your intuition tell
you
to capture back with uh in this position
uh so what you have to do is capture
with the pawn now this
uh does two things uh for one it
improves your uh
pawn uh well central pawn structure now
the pawns are for example covering all
of these squares and one when you start
pushing those pawns it could be very
scary
but more importantly it gets rid of the
weakness here on f7 because as long as
that pawn is there you either have to
push it
or move the king which wastes wastes to
move so here uh
f captures on e6 and is the way to go so
congratulations to everyone who decided
for that
uh but uh king captures is what was
played in the game
i will show what happens if f captures
because it's very interesting
for example king c4 you go after the b6
pawn black goes d5
check king b6 king d6 and now after you
grab the pawn
we have captures captures and now uh
this beautiful
rook the b8 check move and now if uh
white uh moves somewhere you're gonna
lose the pawn so you can try defending
that
uh but now black just keeps on checking
and there's no way uh
to to escape checks check check check
your check and then uh if you wanna
uh if you don't want to draw by
perpetual you're going to have to move
the king at some point and then you're
going to capture on b4
and then the king is now cut off on the
a file the rook controls the entire b
file and it doesn't matter that you have
a past a pawn it's just uh i mean
you can't move the king away from the
from the a file and once black starts
pushing his pawns it's going to be a
winning position for black
so definitely the way to go f captures
here but king captures was played and
now we have king to c4 and now it's a
bit different
because now if you try something like d5
check king b5 and
something like this it captures on b4
captures uh it doesn't matter
because for example if rook to a8 you're
just going to create a pass pawn
captures captures and then now you get
this position where the king is not cut
off on the a file but rather you can
just
very very simply play uh moves like
pushing the pawn and bringing the king
closer to the rook and that's it
white should be able to win this game
but instead after king c4 we have g5
this is what harvests wanted he wanted
to open up the g
file and now king to b5 morphe goes
after the b6 pawn
a captures on b for a c captures on b4
and now
g captures on h4 so creating a an
opening here for the rook uh but here
king captures on b6 and now morphe has
two connected pass pawns on the queen
side
and that's not uh not a very pretty
sight for harvest so here uh if you go
after the pawn
you simply cannot stop the past pawn you
can try rook g1
a6 you're gonna go rook to a1 and then
after a7 that's just it king b7 and a8
to win the game
so instead after king captures on b6 we
have rook to b8 with
check and now king back to a5 but now
it's different you don't get
to check the white king to infinity
because after this rook to be a check
you have king c4
that's that's the good stuff and if d5
checking b3
and next you're gonna play b5 king b4 a5
a6 and so on
so instead after king a5 we have king to
d5
uh but now just rook to d3 check uh so
here uh
harvest wants to prevent morphe from
escaping with with the king
but morphy will not allow this king to
d3 rook to d3 check king to c4
trading the d-pawn for the b-pawn and
morphe accepts uh very gladly
rook captures on b6 and now rook
captures on b4 and now
the position is completely winning for
morphe but you have to do one
very particular thing so feel free to
pause the video here and
win the game for morphe while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are were able
to do it congratulations on
noticing that you have to go into king
and pawn end game and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's uh
either rook to b6 or rook to d4 with
check both of these
moves are winning morphe of course
played rook to d4 check because it's
flashier but
we can also play rook to b6 because this
is the same we force a rook trade
and after captures captures our passport
is winning but you also but you have to
be a little bit careful for example
f5 uh a5 f4 now you don't get to push a6
uh first you have to play f3 otherwise
black will get this move in f3
captures and then the h pawn also is
queening so you have to
uh you know watch out for for stuff when
you're pushing past pawns
so f3 and now just push the pass pawn to
victory
but instead morphe went for the much
flashier rook to d4
check we have king captures king
captures and now it's pretty much the
same thing
f5 morphe immediately stops it with f4
and now uh harvest tries to go after the
g2 pawn to create the past
h pawn but now morphy just starts
pushing his pass pawn a5 king f2 we have
a6
king captures on g2 and now a7 uh we
have h3
but now a8 and this also comes with
checks so first harvest has to move the
king
king to g1 and now queen to f3 and it
was in this position on mu 48
uh that daniel harvey's resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
so really really uh really really
awesome stuff
uh the point is if you push the pawn
then just uh one little check wins the
game queen g3 check you remove the king
and then morphe gobbles up all of the
pawns
or you go king to h1 but just queen to
f2 and
there's no stalemate because you have
this uh this terrible
pawn uh you will have to move it and
then queen to f1 is checkmate
so this is how the game ended morphe won
game six and now this is his fourth
win in a row and it's uh really really
uh incredible how morphe bonds back and
just you know kept through
to his word uh of not allowing harvest
to win a single game after losing two
games in a row
uh but uh interestingly harvest uh said
uh if you remember in the previous game
he took a
a week's rest or rather some eight to
ten days of rest and morphe said okay
you can rest for as long as you want but
then when we continue the match
we play every day sunday is excluded but
now after losing this game
uh harvest again uh requested a timeout
and the morphe
wasn't very satisfied but he there there
was really anything he could do
uh so instead of uh you know uh feeling
bad about it morphe announced that he
will hold
yet another simultaneous blindfold
exhibition against eight opponents
in paris like he did in birmingham and
you know
every other place he visited and people
were very very happy about this so
while our good friend daniel harvest is
recovering from this
unspeakable thing that's happening to
him uh we are going to cover some of
those blindfold simultaneous games as uh
maybe even all of them i don't know uh
there could be some really really
awesome ones
uh but we're definitely going to cover
them that we're then going to continue
the match with harvest uh but
that's not the whole thing because there
are two
extremely strong opponents that are
riding from from
a certain part in france over to meet
morphy in paris
uh they're you know not just coming to
play chess they also want to do some
sightseeing maybe check out
the opera uh and you know the good good
things are
uh are happening uh so yeah
uh that's uh the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
theodorous eliades who uh wishes happy
birthday to kiriakos he's his good
friend
i'm joining the the congratulations as
well happy birthday man
uh my enormous but uh francis ire uh
damian yordanov and alex brijhotko for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up uh on everything that's
happening in the world which is a
really really huge tournament that
starts tomorrow so we're also gonna
cover that
and whatever else happens uh in the
chess world as we usually do
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day
hope you enjoy i hope you're enjoying
the saga so far and if you're only
joining us
there is a link in the description below
first thing you will see uh where you
can start the entire morphe saga from
the beginning
see you soon